try and program their children um
advocated for the slave programming
they're trying to put it in my brain for
it primarily because it's less
stigmatizing than other terms
this is haram
haram send her to saudi
let her repeat this
haram
we need the will of god we need allah
we've been told that uh they're out to
kill us all salaam alaikum brothers and
sisters we went to the streets to ask
americans about islam
here's what they said do you know
anything about islam
no do you know anything about islam
no sadly do you know anything about
islam
not really do you know anything about
islam
no i'm sorry you know what islam means
islam uh
no we've been told that they're out to
kill us all
that's what you've been told
that muslims are out to kill you all
well that's what i say on tv
anything
i know it's in the middle east isn't it
well that you're gonna have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many americans who don't
know about islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
center the first mega dawah center in
america we have 500 000 left and we need
your help to finish click to donate
right now may god almighty allah reward
all of you
subscribe if you haven't already hit
that notification bell and i have a
exciting guest exciting episode he's
here in chicago
with me my brother shabir how are you
how are you doing brother alhamdulillah
yeah we got to give you a new nickname
gabriel the beast
yes
it's nice having you how you feeling
alhamdulillah yeah amazing amazing
alhamdulillah got to uh we got some good
uh some good nutrition today some
training that was beautiful yeah good
night
yeah
so how was uh how was your trip well
alhamdulillah is the most kind
short trip short trip
long overdue yeah yeah i think last time
we met was like what four or five years
ago yes
back uh
in chicago here after all these years
our first interviews in chicago 17 years
back originally right yeah back in the
day 17 years
romanian and loving islam yeah yeah that
was beautiful
so that's one thing for sure is that
time is uh continuing to pass
and then
it's not we're not gaining it we're
losing it
you know we're losing time i mean
it's just uh
you're never going to be able to buy
time yeah that concept buy me time is
just doesn't work yeah
it's faster we realize then the faster
we can stop messing about and
get serious
yeah
so i wanted to share this clip with you
and get your feedback
it's
a reality that me might be coming to a
masjid near you
so it's uh hit the uh churches
and
i want to see uh what we can kind of
unpackage
from this
her name is britta filter and she is the
queen of new york
do you not want to shy away from uh
controversy but this is something that
is
for some people might be controversial
but for others
it's not like
these were topics that many khatibs
many scholars you know they would avoid
these topics but now it's coming to a
masjid near you it's coming to the
churches
so
it's affecting our children it's in the
public schools it's a teacher
that's kind of not a guy and not a girl
like somewhere in between oh you're kind
of boring
kinda yeah yeah that's me okay right on
i want to be a boy but i don't like
being a girl you know what every you
know you have choices in this world to
be all sorts of different things but
that's why it's mx so
mix chavez that's where that comes from
i know some of you were a little
confused some of you came and talked to
me about it
what is it
some people do identify that way i'm
actually trans so i'm not a tomboy i'm
trans
but some people do and i'm sure if they
wanted to they could also go by mix
in their classroom
any other questions
[Music]
do you have any other questions or can
we move on
so now it's like it's being pushed like
we're coming to get your children
we're coming to
push our way upon you it's not being
left in the privacy of your own homes
what do you have to say when you see
something like that
first thing i would ask is how the how
do we get here
in the first place
i think a lot of people don't
they say oh you know it's not my
business or
this is a free country everyone can do
whatever they want there's a lot of
excuses
but no explanations
people give excuses
when it comes to like explain to me how
did we get here
and it goes back to
you know the process em said
it is
if you don't
feel shy you'll do anything you want
or as you please
that's exactly what's happening this is
a church
now a church even though it's deviated
from the path of god right there's only
one path
people you know was talking someone the
other day i was explaining look
he's like oh islam is a religion i said
islam is not a religion there is no such
thing as religion in the side of allah
there's deen
there's a way
and this this is always been the same
way
people i don't know sometimes they try
to put you in a box you're this you're
that
you're not it's even the muslims if
you're not on the deen you're not on
deen it doesn't matter your name is
muhammad
if you're not on the deen you're not on
it's always been the same deen
from the first to the last it's going to
be the same same way only one way right
blossom he draws line in the sand
straight line so this is the path of
allah
they drew sidelines so this is the path
of shaytan i mean every deviation you
could call a
religions that came out left and right
in the end they're all
the prophets that came all brought the
same message
but um how would you translate deen deen
it would be a a way
people say a way of life but then people
like well buddhism is a way of life
i mean it is a way of life but it's it's
the way
it is the way that allah has chosen for
his people
and it's always been the same it's never
been different religions there's no
linear
oh it first came this one and then a new
religion and a new religion and it's
always been one religion
one way one d in one path one life
it's like a train that's going to uh
to a destination
it's the same it's not going to go like
it's just straight man
some people get on it some people get
off it
some people get
excited they look outside oh wait wait
stop stop i want to get off
right and then they get off
some people stay
you just gotta write it all the way
but it's always been the same
but
the process i'm saying if you don't if
you have no shyness you're gonna do
whatever you want and the fifth of the
human being as such
well allah created it
that
if it's not
protected and fine-tuned
by the revelation the why
then
you you you corrupted
and this is what we're seeing right now
a church is a deviation from the path of
god
but as in the quran as it says
that
if you know allah would not check the
nation with the other one there would
have been much corruption in the masajid
in the synagogues in the churches where
the name of allah is mentioned
of course it's a deviation but
even according to christian standards
the church was a place of god okay
putting aside the theological
differences which of course they're
wrong
but it was considered still
a place got all still like
50s 60s 70s you wouldn't see such things
like what we just saw with the this was
unacceptable like people would have an
uproar so this this is uh
technically uh a man
who's dressed
as
a stripper
it looks like uh i guess and um
you sh you're in a house of worship it's
supposed to be supposed to be a house of
god yeah
and you have like you're bringing this
kind of behavior
that is
more conducive to a strip club
why are you bringing it to a church why
are the orthodox jews can you bring this
to a synagogue do you think they they
would allow this i don't think they
would allow it but i don't know what's
going to happen maybe they will sooner
or later maybe the muslims are going to
lie
yeah you got now mosques that are
you know gay mosques
things are changing fast
the question is again how did we reach
here
because we allowed these things to
happen
if people are not careful it's easy to
corrupt your fitra
fitra how would you translate fitrah
it's basically what allah created with
the natural disposition
it doesn't mean you're perfect but allah
has created you in a in the best way
clean
okay you're clean
however within this fitra allah has also
put
certain
you're susceptible to certain deviations
for example the the soul the nephs
desires
if a person follows their desire they'll
corrupt their fitra yeah it's just allah
has told us allah has told us people
were like why did allah didn't put us in
this way why did he create us like that
why did allah create shaytaan if he knew
he was going to he said
if he does what he wills
he cannot be asked he is the creator of
the heavens and the earth he said you
know that uh
the people think they'll be left alone
just to say we believe and they'll not
be tested actually the word here life
tone is the word is fitna they'll be put
in fitna
why
we don't know allah is testing us like
you can't just claim that i'm uh i'm a
good fighter
right and then you're not gonna fight
someone's gonna challenge you on that
right people claim all kinds of stuff
today you're gonna be challenged you
can't just claim i'm a believer i'm an
upright person and you're not gonna be
tested on that belief
it's just allah has made the law like
that
so
like how did we reach here though again
like how can someone allow
i think even more shocking is the amount
of people are supporting this
the amount forget about the amount of
people who don't see a problem with it
the amount of people who keep quiet
and
this is where we're going because
first we didn't we were against it
people were against this kind of
behavior not just this
a lot of
um
immoral
unethical
degenerate type of belief you know
behavior
people are against it they stood against
it they passed laws against it
but what happened is
after some time
people started being conditioned through
media movies slowly slowly you keep
pushing pushing pushing and you're not
aware
that's how the fitra changes is a
prophecy being fulfilled prophet
muhammed saw some he talked about
promiscuity yes rampant
promiscuity the process said that time
will not be established till men will
satisfy their desires with men and women
with women
so this is prophet the last of one of us
just kind of muhammad peace be upon him
yeah he said this yes and look what's
happening
you know you keep pushing someone and
they're not pushing back
you know imagine you're in a fight in a
boxing match and you're just allowing
someone to pound you you go in a corner
just crunch down you're gonna you're
done you have to push back
we look into the history
after sexual evolution all the laws that
were passed where people just kind of
laid back they got busy
with entertainment
with movies then social media came in
people were busy they didn't care about
and slowly they were demoralized
the brain changes
everything you see
you watch you listen to even the
slightest thing brother
five seconds
tick-tock
it changes you
it and the more imagine you're watching
that every single day you're listening
you're here it's the repetitive effect
in psychology we call it the repetitive
effect
even if you don't agree with it first
trust me if you keep watching that stuff
within two years
three years four years don't worry they
have patience
it will happen you'll agree with it not
just you'll agree with that you'll start
promoting it and that's what happened
like we used to hate we were against it
then we became
all more almost like decent like we said
you know it's not a big deal so first
we're against it next thing we're like
you know i don't have time for it it's
not a big deal whatever let people do
whatever they want i'll do whatever then
slowly people start saying well it's not
so bad
and now they're promoting the these
solicitation just keeps slowly happening
happening happening like before you just
people had an issue with this kind of
behavior like yeah the more you go back
if you look at um what's that the lucy
show i remember um
they had the different shows where you
wouldn't even have
the couple sleeping in the same bed let
alone kissing on tv let alone doing
anything anymore i mean this is here
in america i was i was looking at some
pictures from lake shore
the beach here they this was i think the
early 1900s and they were almost like in
the sunnah they weren't you couldn't see
no skin no skin what was that like early
i think just pre-work first world war
just yeah daytona daytona beach can you
imagine
women were being uh given uh fines for
wearing shorts this is the daytona beach
yeah they're being fined so this is
probably most beaches in america now
someone says that's old-fashioned but
you're telling me no that's
that's the natural way most people if
they're if they're a god-fearing
religious any kind of people who want to
live a morally upright life they'll be
like they can connect with what you're
saying yeah because the fitra is allah
has created shyness into humanity they
can identify and they say yeah i'm with
these guys this is exactly i can agree
with this yes but how far have you gone
off were you like look where we are
right now like you're talking about
covering
to nudist beaches yeah i look at the
extreme why what's changed the people
change their bodies change well maybe a
bit
but
what changed is we we lost our
our ethics and morality we did we lost
our shyness we don't see a problem with
doing it
yeah so it's um
it's just a lot of programming
um advocated for slave programming
they're trying to put it in my brain for
it primarily because this is haram
haram
the slave programming they're trying to
put it in my mind it hurts me a lot of
programming
it's uh for me that's the thing
that now is upsetting to a lot of
christians
jews religious people
muslims is that you have these
curriculums are being set up you're also
you're a school principal you're
somebody who has
a master's in psychology is it or
your background is in this in mental
health and
counselor for currently and for many
years so you see the traumas you deal
with a lot of these issues
and what has
is happening is that now
systematically now they're injecting
things into the children at
such a young age from kindergarten to
two years of a second grade it's one
curriculum and they're putting this
stuff in
you as a parent
i should be able to teach my children
right
deem fit why are you pushing the
sexuality and pushing all of this stuff
that you know
it goes against our moral values
and
um and
we have to just swallow it yeah i mean
if you put if you're sending your
children to these institutions
yeah i've been a principal for many many
years i mean i'm working on my master's
right now as well
in counseling and been a counselor for
many many years almost two decades
um
they know
that the formative stages
are the early stages and that's what
they're targeting i mean for you and i
doesn't know
yeah it's not a question coincidence
pushed conspiracy apart this is a
conspiracy
right they know exactly where they can
get people and desensitize them
and
if you look at uh the psychologists who
push this like kinsey for example alfred
kinsey
um that's what he wanted basically like
a fluid sexuality these were sexual
deviants themselves
when you look at their work horrible you
know if you look and you study their
work even sigmund freud you know the
grandfathers of psychology you look at
some of their writings and you would how
would people celebrate this
how
why not not even not now we're talking
about back then where still morality was
to an extent upheld in the church in the
house
conservative states and so on policies
but
they know
that children can be
molded
the fitra is the fitra
every person is born in fitra and then
his parents meaning the environment this
hadith can be extrapolated and extended
to so many different things
these parents convert them and change
them into a christian jew followership
it's not just about the religion here
it's about the fact that a person can be
changed through conditioning
especially at certain
ages and that's where these people
are targeting and my question again is
how did it get to this point that they
can influence laws
they can pass legislation you know why
because we allowed them to
right because if you look at the legal
system okay yeah you vote your
your representative but then it's a very
small pool of people who decide really
what the laws that are passed
but people didn't protest people are too
busy within the means of the law to you
you can you can that's the thing that
i'm trying to violence people are not
breaking the law
the law allows you yes and that's where
you see right now a lot of reversals
taking places
right a lot of like 2022 was a bad year
for these people because there have been
some laws that were reversed
right was it bad people it was a bad
year for abortion
yeah it was a bad year so why because
within the law we're not asking here
people you know we don't want to go
we're wise we're not as we're not afraid
i'm not i'm not scared of anyone but i'm
wise we got to be wise you got to know
where you are
right you can't be just a loose cannon
but within the system
you can do a lot the problem is that no
one's doing anything
and people are holding hands with the
wrong people
you know
what's wrong with the muslims getting
together with conservative christians
and jews and fighting for the same
ethics and morality absolutely why are
they holding hands with the wrong people
and promoting that that's some you know
it's like
and now you people are switching what
depends which way the wind blows all of
a sudden now you got people coming
because you have this is uh something
that
conservative christians
like you said and conservative also jews
and others the soul abrahamic faiths and
judah christians okay let's
agree upon this thing yeah we have
different theologies no doubt about it
but here in the issues of ethics and
morality there's a lot of agreement yeah
so work together
why are you working with the wrong
people to corrupt
the morality
of your own people send the wrong
message send the wrong message because
all their minorities were minority you
scratched my back
scratch you're going to leave a lot of
wounds on my back by scratching me
like this is it doesn't make sense
but you see under pressure
people melt that's when you know
oh there's a bit of pressure oh let's
join hands with with these groups and
those groups no you're supposed to push
back even if you push along the process
right
allah says stand for justice
even if it's against yourself
yeah did you see those they had some
videos and because you have a lot of
these teachers
who are coming out on the tick tock and
videos and they're talking about
pledge allegiance to the flag so during
3rd period we have announcements and
they do the pledge of allegiance i
always tell my class
stand if you feel like it don't stand if
you feel like it say the words if you
want don't have to say the words so my
class decided to stand but not say the
words my room does not have a flag it
used to be there but i took it down
during covid
because it made me uncomfortable
and um
i packed it away and i don't know where
and i haven't found it yet but my kid
today goes hey um it's kind of weird
that we just stand and then you know we
say it to nothing i tell this kid
we do have a flag in the class that you
can
pledge your allegiance to and he like
looks around he goes
oh that one
the
inclusive
pride flag
i pledge allegiance to the queers of
this color movement
and alphabet movement
and then the whole again young children
and then they're
discussing today the boy is
talking about
identifying as being a girl
and sending these mixed signals children
i mean you know i mean you're an expert
in this area i mean how confused are
kids just in general at a young age
they're naive you know they're not fully
developed and if they want to be gi joe
and they're playing they want to be now
you're just capitalizing off this see
it is dolme
it's oppression
because the child
so we're trying to save the children man
it's saving the children from
disappointment the child cannot discern
between right or wrong
but they have
a lot of
ideas
they're creative allah has blessed them
with a lot of skills
and in they have inquisitiveness
they want to learn
this is part of the fitra
but again
islam revelation
submission to the creator
came to guard
the fitra
and people might say you know you guys
are very strict
but when you understand why that
strictness
look around
then you see that it indeed it makes
sense we're trying to protect
these children it's not fair it's
oppression
for someone to target a child who does
not understand cannot make their own
choices
let's say for example
a a
girl
is playing with cars
back in the days it was like not a big
deal i mean she might play a little bit
and get out of it
and go with the girls
or her mom might say look this is not
just go with the girls and she might say
yes okay
now
you're told oh maybe there's a boy
inside of you
because only boys like cars or something
like that you know something silly
and it confuses them
and then they start looking online and
do girls like cars and the first thing
you're gonna
see is all kinds of weird messages and
blogs and support groups
back in the days you would have
uh one of the
activists who goes against
um
conversion and gender conversion and
uh people transiting
he's done it and he's regretting it he's
gone back he's telling young people
don't do it
he said when i was young
i was i started wearing girl's dresses
it was something because it was around
he said my grandma put it on me
and that was a pressure because should
have told me
no
and at that age you just know
the child slowly gets
the message
but right now
people tell maybe
you need to explore maybe this maybe
that there's just so much pressure
that's being pushed on you that people
are confused
we used to have you know i mean
ssa and problems now it's not even that
it's about like you don't even know who
you are what's your gender even though
you can always look it up and see
everything is male female yeah
but people are saying you know that i
don't know what i am
i'm trapped in this body
you you've seen those uh videos story
time
this has been my first year in preschool
with a class of my own teaching
alongside another queer neurodivergent
educator and we have been rocking our
two's class we've been talking about
gender and skin color and consent and
empathy and our bodies and autonomy it's
been fabulous but our teaching team is
shifting and a new person is being
onboarded so today at the lunch table
when the topic of gender and genitals
came up one of our students plainly
looked up and said well i'm a girl today
but i know that teacher co isn't
no they're envy and the look on the
incoming teacher's face was priceless
she just looked around at the two of us
and said this class is incredible and i
am so impressed
i've seen the people the people i deal
with the people
so is that why now when you have an
individual
such as this individual
here who i'll bring out who there's a
lot of talk
about him now and
you know he says some things that are on
point i'm going to let you react to to
this video here leave the kids alone if
you want to chop
nothing against that i'm not anti-gay
i'm not anti-transgender i'm not
anti-any of these things what i'm what i
am auntie is propagating your world view
on other people's children if you're gay
and you can't have kids why do you now
believe it's your right to go to other
people's kids and tell them how to think
if you've decided that the type of sex
you want to have will prevent you from
recreating from procreating that's your
decision right you've decided that
having sex with women isn't worth it for
you you don't want to have children you
want to have sex men fine your decision
and you're entitled to it that does not
give you the entitlement to go to other
people's families who did decide to have
children and raise them and try and
program their children leave the kids
alone you can be as transgender as you
like don't come talk to my kid about it
that's my child i will program my child
with my world views i raise them i pay
for them they're my kid they're not your
kid and they're not the government's kid
and this is what i was saying earlier
about women being blank slate same with
children right you either program your
woman and program your children or
society will do it do you believe the
lessons that society are putting inside
of people today are good lessons i don't
i don't i will not send my kids to
school i don't think they're gonna learn
anything do you know how many teachers
i've seen pissed out of their minds
[ __ ] corner on on
pub toilets on cocaine i'm a teacher huh
you ain't got
my kid you're in it
right i can
we have the internet we have unlimited
information i can say google world war
ii write report boom talk tomorrow and
with discipline my kid will know more
than any kid in any public school
without the indoctrination without all
propaganda that's what all this [ __ ]
all this [ __ ] deliberately deliberate
governments know what they're doing when
they're trying to propagandize and and i
think a lot of people do not understand
yet because most people still live
inside of the matrix there's your buddy
from romania
you're romanian also i'm romanian but
he's not actually romanian no he just
lives in romania lives in romania but
that that kind of talk doesn't
work in romania it just it works on
youtube but not in romania i'll tell you
that so what do you think i mean he's on
point on a lot of things obviously
number one is he's like
he said oh i don't mind this i don't
mind that we mind that you know he
doesn't mind it but we mind it he needs
islam
and then he would mind it too yeah
so we mind that like he said i don't
care if you were this or that no we care
because that's where it starts from see
that's the problem his mentality is
wrong he says a lot of good things
that are
attractive flashy but he's missing the
point
i'll give an example he says i don't
care if you are trans or this or gay
just don't come to my children it's like
saying i don't care there's a fire on my
house i'm going to put it off or if
people start lighting fires as long as
it doesn't come to my house dude come on
man wake up
these people are more dangerous than
fire
you think it's not going to come to you
imagine there's like a bunch of people
you're in the village your house is safe
got your family
safe and as a man
you're saying
oh i can see all these people lighting
fires
around my house it's okay as long as you
just do it in your own place
i don't care
just don't come to my house and light my
own house on fire people are gonna be
playing with fire a lot around your
house guess what your house is gonna get
burned
you have to you can't always be on a
defense or just leave me alone i'll
leave you alone that's that's not islam
that that's
someone who doesn't have islam but now
imagine if he had that's we'd love for
him to now you know take that step
forward because he agrees with you know
man andrew tate man just take the team
man come on andrew you gotta come up
but imagine if he had because it's hard
now to go ahead and measure according to
khan tsunami he don't have it he's on
point with a lot of things but imagine
if he had
that
guidance
living by the crown of sunnah now he
came across the hadith where the prophet
muhammad peace be buzzing upon himself
if you see an evil go ahead change your
channel with your hands if you can't
change your hands your mouth say yes
or at least hate it in your heart right
but he did but now a person doesn't have
that
they're going on i love this hadith yeah
let's let's we need to connect this
because let's start from the back yeah
what did the process was
and that is the weakest of iman when you
just hate in your heart that's the
weakest level yeah
okay let's say
our ummah right now hates because no one
is actually gonna change it by their
hand yeah
we lost that
it'll be nice within the law i think
people could change with their hands
i think even here in north america if
enough people
get together
whatever
whatever they do you know people are
going to say
that's the point that people didn't get
involved they're passive
i'm not going to talk about
the
of what you can do vote this and that
all i'm saying is look at the reality
a lot of people became very passive
christians whoever
muslims of course
and this is what happened we're coming
to get your children right that's what
it is they're i mean it got to that
point where i'm going to talk smack in
your face and tell you in your face that
i'm coming to get you and you can't do
anything about it you know when you're
like taunting someone yeah or you're
teasing me with that song yeah why are
they doing because they can't but then
they they turn around it's like a joke
and this is for real it's for real
disney
look at all the fortune 500 companies
everyone pretty much is supporting this
how do you think they got to that point
disney
disney your children are watching disney
what do you think there's no condition
do you understand the neuropsychology of
it the neuroscience of it everything you
watch it affects us called it it's
called an influencer because it
influences you that's why it's called a
program because it programs you
right but if you don't change with your
hand within the system you can but no
one does it because everyone's sorry
their people are cowards
okay at least speak against it
no one wants to speak again say either
because oh i'm going to lose my job well
so what
but but do you think now when they see
him someone like andrew tate and then
they compare look at many of the
community leaders that's why people
gravitate towards so he's speaking even
more even though he don't have the deen
islam but then but his fitra calls him
to say that this is wrong but then you
have people some community leaders won't
even speak that much but you see with
with like
a lot of our community leaders and i
know this is you know
i don't know people can react and do
whatever leave it in the comment section
just keep it there right i don't care
honestly but this is the reality
it's not my ego though i don't care
about anything it's really that i care
but i don't care if you want to cancel
us or comment or you know say brother
you guys are talking about this what do
you think you are this is the reality we
have reached this point because a lot of
our community leaders
did not say anything
and now
families are coming to with their
children to us as counselors say please
fix our children
my kids are this this this man you know
what what do you mean fix them now
where are the khutbahs that talk about
this oh you get canceled or you get
pulled your funding away so what
who provides allah provides not just
look at our numbers we don't have a
problem with money
the proposal seems i don't fear for for
my own poverty
we we don't have look at our numbers
like the form of the sea
like if anyone cancels you removes your
your funding or
can we not come all together and just
re-establish that system we can
do we want to that's the problem
do you see this being a reason why many
christians are seeing islam as the last
hope now they're seeing because islam
doesn't now they're starting to realize
why islam is strict on so many things
the submission to the creator that
happens in earth islam
has guidelines and you can't like now
kind of just like a buffet mix it up and
we'll do it this way one day weekend and
we'll bring the you know the stripper
into the church to draw people in who's
actually a man well no
no it's islam is strong
as a system
the question is are the muslims strong
because islam is only going to be as
strong as the practicing of the muslims
and the prophet said you will follow
them into the hall of lizard
i'm not trying to insult anyone here but
this is hadith we're not shying away
from
and they say
this another prophecy yeah who the
christian who else he said
literally said who
look at else
they're doing they're they're
they're
disrespecting their places of worship
and what are the muslims gonna do guess
what we're already starting to do that
as well
right because again if you don't change
things if you are not proactive
everything is on the defense
then guess what someone's going to push
unto you it's just the law that allah
has designed for the universe if you get
pushed and you don't push back you're
going to get pushed more
right but look at the last part he said
that then hate in your heart and that's
the weakest of iman
meaning you're at your weakest level
okay if all the muslims would hate it
we would say we're at the weakest level
of our iman
the problem is that a lot of muslims
don't even hate it anymore so what kind
of weakness is that it's even a level
below that so then it comes to the
decessitation that's been happening
over time how did you get it let it get
to that state of getting so desensitized
and that is that systematic approach if
you're sending your children to these
institutions you're kind of
setting yourself up
you're setting yourself up and like
it's even more than that today
so would you say like this is this
should i mean your borderline
you know this is a big big word to use
but would you say many scholars have
said that it's
it is haram it's to send your children
to the public schools yes some have said
it's haram
just like it's like
some have said it's like flushing your
children down a toilet spiritual suicide
you know because you see what's
happening right now no doubt it is
unless you're sitting there every day
debriefing them every day you know every
day you're right but how many people do
that and the problem is that it's bled
into the muslim countries as well
it's bled from the public schools into
the islamic schools i work with islamic
schools and some of the issues that
we're having
are huge
so let's go to islamic schools because
you'll have a curriculum that they'll
copy from the public schools so they
some just are they naive they it just
kind of gets past them they got to look
out for it if they're taking it and
putting it into their school they have
to look out for some of these things
that are being taught yes you have to
filter you got to be careful you got to
adjust but then again within the law
what are you allowed to do right because
they they're pushing you to make sure
that your kids are exposed okay you want
to have your islamic school no problem
go ahead
but you got to follow our curriculum
so yeah you call it islam but still
you're following our curriculum
and in the end if you don't then we can
pull your funding or your licensing and
so on and so forth but how do we even
get to the point i just still can't wrap
my mind around it you know when you go
back to
your men
your grandfather or your grandmother at
a certain time this is y and people say
oh this is old school this is like
old-fashioned now it's like the 20-23
almost and now
you you're born as a
male or female but you can change that
later that's that gender fluidity how do
we get to that point this is something
that just so there's no science to back
it up it doesn't carry any weight with
any religion
with god obviously but with science with
logic it just makes no sense but you got
half the country are starting to become
divided and accepting of this and i how
do you just
look doesn't make any sense when you go
from a time when it was just this is not
something even up for discussion right
all this gold brother
yeah and that's what process says he
said that the best generation is my
generation and then after and after hey
in many hadith again prophecies like
people need to look how did it process
them know these things
right the prophet said first will be
prophecy
uh it will be manhattan nubua then
rightly
you know corruption he talked about
everything yeah
what what we can extrapolate from this
hadith is that there's a
um there's a progression yeah or you can
say a degeneration because you said my
the first generation is not the best one
yeah and then aft and then it will go
down wow so it's just you guys
yeah that's what we're having right now
why is because
allah subhanahu ta'ala i mean created us
in such a way
that we are easy
to be guided or misguided hence teachers
who are
having master's degree very intelligent
and now
they don't want to stand out and they
have a few others who are like really
passionate and they really are pushing
this and now
you have them just kind of
following the herd that's it
people don't wanna they're scared to
talk they're scared to oppose yeah
they're like we can't even have a
discussion
this is this is how how far it's gone
that they passed legislation where
you're not even allowed to have a
discussion it can be called
discrimination can be called
you know a hate speech and so on why did
i even reach there if you are so
confident about what you are trying to
put on people here
with your curriculum
then let it be debated if you're so
confident it's actually very very clear
i want people to think about it if these
people are saying that you're born this
way
that's the argument
if these people are saying that they're
so confident about what they're offering
to the world
then let it be up for debate
why are you limiting cancelling people
if someone wants to oppose you
with science with argumentation
let it let the best person win isn't it
i see they're scared because they know
what they're doing no you're not born
like that you're born pure
but yes you can be corrupted
and the corruption of today brother
again
what we're faced with 21st there's been
all kinds of corruptions there was
hollywood there was bollywood there was
tv but now
with social media
it is
accelerated
and these people know and that's why mo
all social media platforms are promoting
this kind of and if you are
by any chance if me and you
talk against it guess what you'll be
demonetized de-platformed
uh banned
shadow band whatever you have these why
did i say let's go and punch in the face
or something
did i say anything like that on the show
did i incite anyone towards hatred or to
be violent towards these people i didn't
say that
all i'm offering is
some intellectual arguments this is uh
free speech yeah where is the free
speech but that but you do have people
pushing back like you had matt walsh
from he's a woman did you i don't know
if you got a chance to have that i have
okay really great documentary yes so
he's really caught a lot of momentum you
have a lot of mainstream also people out
there who are gravitating to it because
excellent he's a voice of logic reason
but you see that this is what proves my
point do you see how easy you can switch
people this way that way yeah the
problem is that there's not many people
who can switch that way
everyone's pushing
towards liberalism
towards
you know
loss of morality and degeneration
and people are going for it because
they're conditioning constantly it's in
their face
if if more people would be pushing
towards morality
then more people probably swing that way
as well and we got to break through
that barrier the wall there because you
have people like matt walsh we invited
him on the program but he works for
this uh ben shapiro right
and you have this
misinformation and these people also
pushing this hate against muslims islam
so now they're scared to work with
muslims but if they would sit
and get to know
muslims and look where we stand on
things
i think they're
look the the agenda of these people is
clear i don't think they're hiding it
mm-hmm
um because we can do a lot of good here
today we can we can we got so much
encounters so much in common and i think
no matter what we can i think
and the the evidence for that is that
prophet sallam would have treaties with
non-muslims
people have different theologies and
they hate islam
and they even fought wars together like
in his army would have certain regiments
of christians arabs and and non-muslims
to fight against the common enemy
[Music]
you can the christian arabs didn't like
the muslims
they were very clear on that they really
did not yeah
you know what i mean so i don't think
this argument is that all these people
hate us or they hate islam therefore we
cannot work on
on certain ethics and morals
so let's hold hands with these other
people because they don't hate islam are
you kidding me
really they don't hate islam
i mean look what they're doing oh oh
yeah we can
leave morality on the side for a bit we
just need to make sure we are protected
and they're protected
of course they hate islam
they don't like islam if they would like
islam they would convert this time
they'll change their life yeah
i i
i am convinced and i strongly believe
that the majority have not
and i think if they've sat with a
qualified
teacher of islam someone who really uh
who lives by the chronic sunnah and can
communicate and answer questions i bel i
believe strongly that
after some
deep discussions and you know if the
person's sincere and genuine i think
this can be broken through and then good
can be accomplished you don't have to
end if someone doesn't accept islam but
still
they can end up being um people that you
can work to together with what do you
think
because there's so much in common
there's so much in common so much good
that we can accomplish together no doubt
and at the end of the day all we're
inviting you to is pure monopoly is
worshipping the one and only one god we
say jesus peace be upon him we don't
insult him you're tag teaming with
someone else who insults jesus his
mother that's another thing i just can't
wrap my mind it's just this is insane i
understand that these conservative
groups have
insulted islam
and have said things that's where the
people push back like how how can you
look these liberal groups have not done
it they respect islam
but as you said if people sit down and
explain to them things
it might be that they'll change their
approach we can defer
no doubt they will differ i mean you
know allah said very clear that not
everyone's going to be guided
right that's why allah created hell for
these people sorry to say
i mean they think they say about us like
don't don't be offended you know why are
you offended you know they think the
same artist yes but we can get the
elephant out of the room get out of the
elephant out of the room man and we keep
moving forward on these other big issues
like i'll give you an example there's a
perfect example i had this um comedian
worked in hollywood he was on the joe
rogan show
he was somebody who was a staunch enemy
of islam insulting prophet muhammad owen
benjamin is his name if you've heard of
him
and he said look i thought muslims hated
jesus
and he was writing for the lauder for
crowder show
and he was writing the scripts for them
he's also made a song with that uh tommy
guy from the uk you know the
robins are
forgot his name right and for he was the
president of the edl or
so he was
writing
a song
against islam again
so tag teaming with someone who hates
muslims hates islam anyways make a long
story short
he was someone who hated muslims hated
islam
and to this day now he's actually
defending muslims in islam
and he'll say things like muhammad peace
be upon him he'll totally had a shift
after he had some exposure to
islam to muslims we had them on the
program
totally different
totally different person you know it's
amazing so and then another thing is
many of his followers for years and
years and years when they saw us
talking together they're like how can we
be so blind we were so like fooled it's
you know to see their positive reaction
of just us to coming together having a
program
talking about some of these things and
that's why i'm really optimistic to see
if we can sit with more conservative
christians we have so much in common
if you look around the
western community we have uh slowed down
in the dalla
you know early 2000s
right there was a lot of doubt going on
now
the the just the amount
the quality is very low
just doubt the christians and
non-muslims yeah
very few people are still doing doubt
it's now more about just being accepted
yeah no it's yesterday one of my clients
was asking me like explain to me the
hadith of the
the strangers yeah
and i said let me tell you one thing
about the hadith
the problem is that we're not strangers
anymore people are saying oh yeah the
muslims are just like us you know come
come welcome
we're so accepted i'm not saying here
that people should hate us
but the process means they started some
strange and return is something strange
meaning you're different than the rest
of people
you're unique
which is attractive if you think about
it people will want to understand the
difference that's what draws people to
islam
when you tell someone you know it's like
kind of like christianity oh really okay
well i don't really need to go right
because i have my own thing it's kind of
like christianity and you know it's all
good oh let's shake hands and have a
coffee great super no problem have a
coffee man but we're not the same
what we're saying is strange too should
be strange to you because it's not the
same what you're saying
that's what the prophet saw when he came
to to mecca with the the message
it was against the culture of that time
but a lot of people are attracted to it
because of that
because they're tired of the
lack of morality and what was happening
in a society
so here's another system that is not
like yours that offers solutions and
that's exactly what islam is if people
would just give it a chance
it will solve all their problems just
name one
name one problem in the world like
people are complaining about
world hunger okay is that guy will solve
that
that's one of the pillars of islam is
that cow will solve this the pillars
zachary will solve world hunger
calculate it
if
only
only a few of the wealthiest people in
the world
okay name but does any other see that
if islam rules the system it's obligated
it's obligatory it will be taken from
you it's not your money it's a tax for
the poor it's a tax report and it's not
your money it's not like whether you
like it to give it or not or alms i'll
give it or i won't give it it's up to me
no
no no it doesn't belong to you
the poor people have to be fed that's
have to be this is their right it will
solve okay give me another problem so
world hunger for sure alcoholism alcohol
for sure but all the gambling gambling
pornography all these expertise sexual
deviations exploitation
everything will the worst the things
that are the
the killers of today breakdown of the
home the family
everything with uh zinna promiscuity
fornication the whole world is
complaining about this problem saying
we're having these problems they have
all these
you know in the united nations 20
million new ones a year
islam
is a solution
it's a solution
for the world problems yeah it's a
solution for
individual it protects you against all
kinds of evils it protects you against
your even yourself
islam is a solution i don't just look at
it just name one problem and you find
that islam has a specific solution right
a person has to be sincere they have to
be open-minded there's so many layers of
layers of deception falsehood and people
that have systematically been put in the
way so people they hear islam they start
thinking all these negative things that
has nothing to do with it but if they
really take some time investigate for
example just yesterday i met a serbian
guy marco
and obviously my parents uh my
background's from bosnia and you know
the history between serbs and bosnians
and whatnot even though we don't just
hate someone because they're
nationalities right yeah
but what happened was he came in to the
mosque he says oh i just want to
introduce myself he just accepted islam
a couple weeks ago he said he watched
this program we did 10 top 10 reasons
jesus is not god
and he started investigating and how he
came at the end
was he wanted to as he's investigated he
wanted to give it one final push so he
went to his uh orthodox christian
pre-priest
and he started asking questions
and instead of addressing things the
preach
priest he started just bashing islam so
he couldn't he said so for them that was
the green light for him to accept islam
because he couldn't he had certain
questions
that the preacher he just didn't
couldn't answer intellectually and he
just started bashing islam so at the end
of the day it's just this push
against islam
with misinformation with falsehood with
attacks but nobody can come against the
la ilaha
you know the pure monotheism
right the
beautiful teachings that like you just
said the solutions for humanity nobody's
our this is like
i challenge people but but let's be
let's be real some people right now
they'll come up because you are an
expert in this area also you know um
being in this field you spent so much
time
going back and someone will try to put a
doubt in your mind they'll bring up the
prophet saws marriage to aisha they'll
bring up some some fake issue they'll
bring up something out there that needs
more more explanations context right
and didn't you do that for some time you
went and you looked into all these
things and you know
even had a website is it still up yeah
dedicated to this alhamdulillah yes we
wrote
hundreds of articles academic articles
and
i could sum up everything in a few
sentences do that please and that is
just because you think something is
wrong
doesn't make it wrong
just because you feel that this is
not ethically correct does not make that
thing wrong
and that's the problem with most people
i had that issue yeah
as i came into islam
because i've been conditioned my whole
life
to have this pacifistic approach to life
and i don't want people to misunderstand
me
you know as allah says in the quran if
they incline towards peace you're
inclined towards peace we don't have a
problem we're not like these
war
you know thirsty people we just want to
fight all the time and whatnot
the default is peace
so
you condition your whole life
in this fake
pseudo
philosophy pseudo peace philosophy
because if you look at it really at
what's happening around the world that
people would claim the most peace are
the ones who are destroying the world
the most
says and when it said to them don't make
corruption upon the earth they'll say
we're peacemakers
i challenge everyone look at the reality
who is causing the most war and
corruption in the world are those who
are claiming to be the princes of peace
that's one eye bro that just gives how
the media spun things straight up
so
i was conditioned by that just like you
were just like you are
whoever's watching right now all the
christians all the jews all the atheists
all the whatever
and i had an issue
with like the the hadoop punishment it
was like it was it was heavy on me yeah
it's causing a lot of cognitive
dissonance you know
it's like you believe one thing but
you're
on the outside is another thing and they
don't align so it causes a lot of stress
and um
i remember one of my friends left islam
for the same reason and that added more
agony to me because i was like man
now you're really being tested
and this guy was praying fajr in the
first line in the messenger
and he was the same thing he was like i
can't believe that her peace religion
will cut the hand of someone who steals
i'm a thief of a thief but if you go
into the jail right now and people are
doing 20 years is they take my hand i
want to get out and they're in
solidarity
you know i was telling someone that in
romania
where our friends there
uh
the politicians or some people are
saying just bring
bring back dracula you know dracula
would implement sharia romania
because he was trained in the court of
the ottomans
and they would say that there was cups
of gold in the in the center of the city
where you get water yeah no one would
touch it was safe because people were
scared because of the deterioration of
this of the amputation yes of the arms
exactly this is not for someone just
like no i'm trying to feed his family no
no this is a specific thing these
and this is a hypocrisy because if you
ask anybody if you had of
a
bag of money under your bed or some gold
in your safe and someone put you and
your family in danger and they came and
they took all that and if you caught
them what would you do and they're
talking about decapitating the person
they're talking forget about the hand
right there
so so you know the remaining
possibilities
you said many people should have their
hands cut off that's what the romaines
are saying what's because
because there's so much corruption
they're saying this yeah there's so many
there's so many criminals so many so
many thieves yeah and who's suffering is
the the normal people
yeah
so so what do you got to worry about if
you're not a thief exactly yes
yeah i mean it doesn't make sense so go
ahead
yeah so he you know when he left islam i
was in a lot of agony yeah i remember i
went to
i went to
to africa
and um
there was this little girl that
approached us to sell herself
and she was you know i was with my
friends it was night i remember
he was like probably like 12 years old
or something
i said five bucks five dollars so like
look just relax you know we're not
looking for this stuff like please and
her pimp was sitting across the street
just look i could see
he's getting nervous in there we're not
accepting
because sadly
they saw people that fit the profile
because that's what happens people come
from the west they go to africa they go
to indonesia malaysia
thailand and they do these things
right that's the degeneration level that
we reached
she's at two dollars i said no she's
crying like please i'm gonna get hurt
and at that time i was still you know
literally even on the flight i was
thinking trying to wrap my head around
this whole sharia thing you know the
punishments
and it clicked in that moment i said if
islam would be here
this girl wouldn't do this
islam would say that yes i would have
saved the young girl and that guy over
there on the other side he deserves a
big punishment
and there was a
paradigm shift in my brain something
happened that night yeah and it all made
sense
but see it was
i first thing i realized was that i
wasn't accepting reality because i felt
it's immoral
or unethical
i felt
i didn't know
i didn't have proof i just felt yeah and
most people just go on feelings
they deny islam
based on how they feel
and they
feel based on how they've been
conditioned for many many years
wake up
so before we close it you think that's
why another reason sorry to keep
bringing up
and we want to send him some love by
giving him invitation to islam but when
he comes out and he's confidently
talking about get the rocks he's like
get the rocks yeah abdul yeah get the
rocks get the rocks
[Music]
hey he's
i'm doing the rocks
and he just like where muslims are
really just shy away and just
but uh andrew tate he's stepping up and
for that reason let's let's invite him
to islam come on listen by andrew tay
andrew tate uh brother humanity again
we're not endorsing a lot of things uh
obviously he does but we understand he's
not muslim yet but let's start off with
uh he's still throwing up and and this
is out of the love and out of respect we
really want because you can give someone
the cars he's got all the cars you give
him the money all the money
the best gift you can give someone is
islam because that's paradise forever
peace inner peace that's uh what i'm
guaranteeing that someone who doesn't
have
that connection with their creator the
way not according to your desires
because you can't be just you know
throwing up trinities and you know
calling god a man and insulting god in
any which way and think that god loves
me and god's proud of me and now
see people like i understand they think
they're strong
but
remove the cars remove the girls remove
the lifestyle what are they left with
will they have inner peace right now
they're happy
because they are
having all these
stimuli
cars the girls the fame the lifestyle
remove that
how are you gonna feel
remove that from me and you like take
everything from me
i don't care
he's like you can't take allah you can't
take my iman
you know you can't my mind's my in my
heart right as she is you know
he said you cannot take my islam away
you can if you wanna uh jail me jail me
that's
time alone my lord
you want to kick me out of the world the
land it's okay it's joel it's just uh
traveling
you can't do anything you want to take
my life you make me a martyr
but you can't take what's inside man
that's the thing take away my car take
away my family take everything in the
end you can't take away my iman only
allah
can do that
so for someone like him who might be
confused and
the first step is to
go ahead and explain because
if he's christian
and he's got problems with christianity
but he's praising islam
if you're praising islam
you agree with many of
the teachings of islam
why don't we explain to him the most
important teaching because if he
understands this if he grasps this then
he can be on his way to saying
the negation and affirmation there's
nothing worthy of worship except the one
who created you entertained that's the
one you want to worship that pure
monotheism
and that goes against you know doing the
whole um
three-in-one and whatnot so let's touch
upon that i i don't i don't even i
really don't think he believes in that i
don't think he believes in the trinity
no it's seeing with owen benjamin he he
also they don't question every human
being
is wired just so people can understand
you come from the background being an
orthodox christian right yeah yeah
every human being is wired for
belief in god
psychologists have discovered a god hot
spot yeah but putting that aside you can
just observe even the atheist just the
amount of time they spend talking about
god your drive is known that okay you're
wired for belief in a higher creator and
higher being
um
so entertain just
in christianity
it's just
for them they think it's just easier to
match their lifestyle and still
be safe and this is the greatest
people are going to be upset but it's
the greatest deception of shaytan
okay the the christian theology
that
god's son
no never mind god himself pretty much
died
for your sins
so you can sin and live the lifestyle
that
andrew lives
but yeah you're still putting on the jc
gold card now that's it that we talked
about before right this is like putting
on jesus back and this is this is the
biggest deception brother because it's
very attractive yeah
i can do whatever i want to
and i got a free ticket to paradise
woohoo never taught brought by any of
the prophets and messengers no one is
dying for your sins never if you want to
go ahead and turn to your creator repent
repent to god
alone that's it we're not make sense
we're not claiming uh here that we are
better than anyone or it's so good or
perfect it's not about that
you think you're better than me it's not
about that it's about which system
offers you salvation
we our salvation is with god
people's salvations is with people
it doesn't make sense that just doesn't
make sense doesn't align with scripture
even with their own scripture that's why
allah says in the quran uh surah i think
let
the people of the injillah
let them stand by what their book says
because they don't even stand by that
that's the problem
what do you want you want to have the
cake and eat at the same time
it's not like that
yes we muslims have a lot of issues a
lot of problems but one thing we're for
certain
that our system is
watertight
and i think you cannot
find any other way of life
that is so adamant about
the
oneness of god and i think this is
something that fascinated me the tohi
the pure monotheism someone trying to
compare muslims uh with the joseph smith
and all that when you look into this
it's so far-fetched because in their
religion they're trying to make you a
god at the end that you're going to
accomplish after this life then you'll
go on to be a deity no one could be a
deity no one can be god god is god the
creation is the creation and this is
something that resonates it goes with
what we talked about earlier
the belief in one and only
one creator nothing worthy of worship
except that one creator
and if he can understand this everything
else should be able to fall in place and
it's easy to understand right
that's right look um
let's say he's having issues it's tough
for him yeah
it was tough for me it was tough for
many people have converted to islam
fine
just say
first yeah don't worry about everything
else right now
because a lot of people when you talk to
him like
what stops him
that they oh i'm gonna have to change my
life i'm gonna have to give up this this
this is true
but it's better to be a muslim
who commits sins
than a non-muslim was righteous so we'll
talk about all those other things with
andrew after
yeah it means there's no deity where
they worship except god the almighty
and then muhammad is final prophet in
messenger just like jesus was a
messenger at his time same statement
same statement at moses's time same
statement
muhammad is the last one it's always
been the same there's no religions
there's no different it's always been
one thing and i love this the negation
there's no deity where they worship so
that can be the cars they're not going
to worship the cars the money
yourself your ego nothing nothing except
the one who created you okay this is so
profound so deep simple it's perfect
it's perfect yeah
that's it so from there we can talk
about the prayer we can talk about
establishing step by step step by step
step by step let's do this
repeat after us
allah
rasulullah that's it come on andrew you
could do it
it's it's it's uh something that uh will
get you to the next step go to sleep
uh saying it
you know
during the day say it and inshaallah
start reading you know i sent you that
book
you know if someone like him converts
islam
putting aside all the differences that
we have
if someone conquers islam you can
imagine how many of his followers would
at least consider yeah or want to be
like why did he like why would him
do that
you can change so many people's lives
towards good
what you're doing right now
i mean then you become a better better
example better better because you'll be
following the best example prophet
muhammad peace be allah upon him who's
the brother to jesus moses abraham they
were brothers in faith in islam yeah
anything else before we conclude i think
we ended it with a good one
the message inviting andrew tate to
islam and also talking about these very
important issues or many people are not
touching upon them okay um
i mean
it's really nice
to spend some time with you having you
with us here may allah god almighty
reward you yeah i mean you're too
shallow
and thank you guys for tuning in another
exciting episode here with my brother
javier on the dean show make sure you
guys go ahead and subscribe if you have
it and um we have the latest project
with the dean center we're trying to get
this up and running so support us there
and we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you i cannot leave without
giving you a gift if you're not yet
muslim and you're tuning in to see what
these muslims are talking about and
you'd like a free copy of the quran go
and visit the deenshow.com we'll take
care of the postage and everything and
get it delivered to you and if you still
have some questions
about islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum and if you like this episode of
the dean show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum